The Fifth Element features an iconic
performance from Chris Tucker but his
part almost went to someone very
different from off-screen relationships
to thoroughly detailed design work this
is the Untold Truth of a 90s sci-fi
classic
two decades before the release of The
Fifth Element director Luke Bayson was
already developing the film's futuristic
world when he was just 16 years old he
was bored living outside of Paris
without a TV or very many friends so as
he explained in an interview with Mr
Showbiz I started to invent this world
where I can be a wild cab driver it was
just a way to escape at first at first
base song conceived of the story as a
novel as he explained to nerdists in
2017 I never thought about making a film
of it so it was a novel for a long time
and then at a certain point 10 years
later I said you know what I would love
to make a film of that for the
futuristic New York where much of the
story takes place besan wanted a mix of
both past and future the goal was to
make the city look as if it had been
partially destroyed and rebuilt in some
places but intact in other spots similar
to how European cities were devastated
during the bombings of World War II
Bruce Willis almost didn't land the lead
role of cab driver Corbin Dallas as
based on revealed in the Reddit AMA he
actually asked Mel Gibson because their
offices were next to each other at
Warner Brothers Gibson considered it but
he eventually passed perhaps because of
that experience the director opted for a
different approach as he explained to Mr
Showbiz when the production began we
made the decision to not go for a big
star we said let's put the money in the
sets the costumes the special effects
like Star Wars 20 years ago basan then
envisioned Willis as the lead though he
figured that he would cost too much
fortunately Willis didn't care about the
money and sought out Bayson to make sure
that he knew he'd be willing to make a
deal if he liked the project as the
actor told Entertainment Weekly in 2017
I just liked Luke I liked the story I
liked the idea I thought it would be fun
to go to France and make a movie that's
a very dangerous gun you know maybe you
better let me hang on to this one for
you huh
the casting call for the pivotal
character of the humanoid woman lilu
included a staggering 8 000 people
Bayson personally met with about 200 to
300 of them including Saved by the Bell
and showgirl star Elizabeth Berkeley
Mila Jovovich was only 19 when she
auditioned and it didn't exactly go well
at least not in the first round
according to besan she was too nervous
and wearing too much makeup but then a
few weeks later they met again and he
gave her another chance and it worked
out much better in the spontaneous
screen test the director put Jovovich
through some bizarre exercises like
asking her to close her eyes and imagine
that she was not from this world then he
observed her reaction as she acted out
the prompt of seeing a common object as
if for the first time Not only was he
impressed with her ability to improvise
he also liked her exotic look as he put
it to Mr Showbiz she can be from the
past or the future she could be an
Egyptian or a Roman she could be
Nefertiti and she can be from outer
space I was built to protect not to love
you're wrong
there's no denying that the fifth
element has its own unique look and a
big part of that has to do with the
colorful and expansive wardrobes costume
designer Jean-Paul Gautier proved to be
an inspired Choice thanks to his ability
to think outside of the box and he
certainly brought that mentality to the
film on a massive scale as he created
over 1 000 costumes Gautier was well
established in the fashion world but he
was relatively new to the movie industry
so he may not have been aware of how
impressive his accomplishment was but
others have certainly acknowledged it
during a retrospective for Gautier at
the Montreal Museum of Fine Arts curator
Tahiri Maxime laurio said a thousand
costumes is like 10 collections but all
for one movie it's an incredible amount
of work people don't even know about for
a thousand costumes he may have even
done 5 000 sketches before narrowing it
down and one particular costume really
stood Out Among the rest you might think
that lilu's iconic bandage dress was
designed only to show Mila Jovovich
nearly nude but there was some reasoning
behind it as the actors playing to Vogue
in 2022 being in a hospital they put a
robe on you that is open in the back so
they can reach in and put injections in
tubes so you have to have as little as
possible but for the sake of modesty you
have to cover up in Luke and John Paul
talked about this bandage idea and
Jean-Paul was like genius I love it
When developing zorg the main villain
played by Gary Oldman Luke base on Drew
from historical sources for inspiration
as he explained to Mr Showbiz you always
see these Christian people these
religious people always fighting for the
noble cause in fact they kill millions
of people through history they fight for
a code but they burn everybody for years
they son collaborated with both old men
and Jean-Paul Gautier to flesh the
character out the director and the
costume designer came up with keywords
to describe the character such as Dandy
Nouveau riche and Hitler basically he
was the type of person who would buy a
Picasso painting because it paired well
with this couch and furthermore As basan
Told Entertainment Weekly it took some
time to get the voice of the character
because he's so extreme so finally
Oldman proposed this sort of half Texan
accent and it was very funny despite the
caretaking to develop his character
Oldman wasn't exactly pleased with his
own work in a 2014 interview with
Playboy he admitted that he's highly
critical of nearly all of his
performances when asked specifically
about The Fifth Element he insisted oh
no I can't bear it NF series one thing I
do not like three it is to be to
disappointed
when casting the fascinating
gender-fluid Ruby Rod Luke basan met
with Jamie Foxx and Chris Tucker the
latter of whom got the part he liked
both actors but he ultimately decided
that Tucker fit the role better since
Fox was built like an action hero and
Bayson wanted to reserve that look for
Bruce Willis but as it turns out Bayson
actually had another star in mind
entirely that would be musician and
occasional actor Prince alas the rock
star proved to be a bit too elusive as
Bayson recalled to Entertainment Weekly
it was a nightmare because he'd give you
an appointment and then he comes like
seven days late and sometimes he shows
up when you don't expect him you can't
grab him you know he was free and he
wants to stay free but when you think
about Prince and then you watch the film
you feel there's a flavor
one interesting aspect about the
character of lilu is that when she
speaks her Divine language there are no
subtitles so viewers might guess that
the lines delivered by Mila Jovovich are
just gibberish but that's not the case
at all Luke basan in fact put a lot of
work into developing the fictional
language to the point that it was
possible to have a real conversation
with it as the Director explained to
Entertainment Weekly in 2017 I wrote a
dictionary with 500 words but we were
the only two who spoke it on the set
Jovovich had to learn it and then we
could talk to each other in it basan
wanted the audience to see lilu through
the perspective of carbon Dallas so just
as the main character couldn't
understand her neither could viewers
activate the phonic detector
The Fifth Element is quite the visual
spectacle we had very little CGI
technology was used to make the film as
practical effects were mostly utilized
instead as Luke based on explained to
Entertainment Weekly in 2017 technology
today is so easy that you can do
whatever you want at the time it was a
nightmare but we used I think only two
green screen shots in all of it and
co-producer Ian Smith revealed that a
lot was accomplished through the use of
model Miniatures as he noted they're not
small things they're big big Miniatures
if you follow me a lot of planning went
into the effects especially for the
massive explosion in flosston and the
large Mangalore alien suits worn by the
actors an entire team was dedicated to
making sure the people inside had enough
air and water during filming there were
also cameras in The Mask so that the
crew could literally tell the performers
where to go as they were completely
blind within them
the cast members of The Fifth Element
naturally grew close to each other
during filming as they would spend a lot
of time hanging out both on and off the
set Mila Jovovich and Chris Tucker in
particular partied together and bonded
over the fact that they both grew up on
the west coast Bruce Willis wasn't as
social as the rest of the cast though
his then-wife Demi Moore did spend time
with them on set as Jovovich revealed to
Entertainment Weekly Demi was on set a
lot and she was rad I would babysit for
them sometimes when I wasn't working I
was so young I probably had more fun
with his kids at that time while Willis
may have been a little anti-social he
did throw a party for everyone at the
end of the shoot during which he played
Jazz for everyone yeah yeah
after Mila Jovovich was hired to play
Lulu she and Luke basan began dating
this was no surprise to co-producer Ian
Smith who told Entertainment Weekly Luke
said to me at one point you realize that
whoever I cast is Lilo I have to fall in
love with them and I understood what he
meant by that he didn't want just some
pretty girl he wanted someone with that
particular individual thing that Mila
had Smith was supportive of the
relationship though as he believed it
would improve the film and he was far
from the only one involved in the
project to notice the couple had hit it
off as Bruce Willis told ew the real
romance was between Luke and Mila by the
time I had gotten to Paris they were
already kind of smitten with each other
in 1997 Jovovich and besan married in
Las Vegas but there was a lot of
controversy surrounding their
relationship as the Director was already
married to my went the actor who played
the diva plava Laguna in The Fifth
Element two years later Jovovich and
basan would split up as well
according to Luke based on he'll never
make The Fifth Element too nor will he
make a sequel to any of his other films
has he put it to Entertainment Weekly no
matter how much you love a film the fun
is to try something else otherwise I'm
gonna do Fifth Element Sixth Element
seventh that's not interesting a
continuation of this particular story
does not make sense to the director
because the intergalactic entity known
as the darkness only emerges every five
thousand years thus the main characters
probably wouldn't be in any potential
sequel as Bayson also noted in a Reddit
AMA it would be hard to up the stakes
after saving the universe in the first
movie however Bayson also made it sound
like he might be open to another film
within the same Cinematic Universe but
it wouldn't be a straight Sequel and it
would have different characters on the
other hand he also joked about a
standalone feature starring Chris Tucker
as Ruby Rod so we probably shouldn't
hold our breaths about any sort of
return to the universe of The Fifth
Element
hello
foreign